VOLUNTARY DEAL THERE.
WE ARE GOING TO SPEAK TO A
JOURNALIST INSIDE THE COUNTRY.
BUT FIRST, MY THOUGHTS AT THE
END OF DAY 38, AMERICA IN
SHUTDOWN.
NOW, REMEMBER WHEN TRUMP SAID
THIS?
>> THE HEAT, GENERALLY SPEAKING,
KILLS THIS KIND OF VIRUS, SO
THAT WOULD BE A GOOD THING.
>> Laura: AND HE GOT CREAMED
FOR IT.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN SAYING IS
THAT BY APRIL IS THE WARMER
WEATHER COMES THIS MAY ALL JUST
MAGICALLY GO AWAY OR MOLECULARLY
GO AWAY.
>> WE’VE HEARD OF THE CDC AND
FDA OFFICIALS.
THEY ARE NOT CONFIDENT THAT WARM
WEATHER IS GOING TO RID THE
WORLD OF THIS.
>> HEALTH OFFICIALS AROUND THE
GLOBE -- PRESIDENT TRUMP IS A
NEW PLAN.
WAIT FOR WARMER WEATHER.
>> Laura: OH, THE SNARK, AND
THEN TODAY.
>> THE VIRUS DIES THE QUICKEST
IN THE PRESENCE OF DIRECT
SUNLIGHT UNDER THESE CONDITIONS,
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT AT THE CHAR
LOOK AT THE AEROSOL WHEN YOU
BREATHE IT, PUT IT IN A ROOM,
70-75 DEGREES, 20% HUMIDITY, LOW
HUMIDITY, THE HALF-LIFE IS ABOUT
AN HOUR.
BUT YOU GET OUTSIDE AND IT CUTS
DOWN TO A MINUTE AND A HALF.
>> Laura: BY THE WAY, I LIKE
THAT GUY AT THE BRIEFING.
HE WAS REALLY COOL.
I LIKE HIM FROM THE MOMENT HE
STARTED SPEAKING.
IT’S GREAT NEWS FOR ALL OF YOU
BEING COOPED UP INDOORS.
IS IT A COMPLETE CHANGE OF
COURSE?
KNOW, BUT IT’S GOOD NEWS.
THE POWER OF FRESH AIR AND
SUNSHINE.
WE ALL INSTANTLY KNOW THAT.
IT’S GOOD FOR A PHYSICAL AND FOR
A MENTAL HEALTH.
IT’S PRETTY OBVIOUS.
BUT REMEMBER, IN THIS NEW
COVID-19 TIME WARP WE ARE ALL
LIVING IN, FOR THE PRESIDENTS
ENEMIES, ANY GOOD NEWS FOR
AMERICA IS ACTUALLY BAD NEWS
NEWS.
>> IS IT DANGEROUS FOR YOU TO
MAKE PEOPLE THINK THEY WOULD BE
SAFE BY GOING OUTSIDE IN THE
HEAT CONSIDERING THAT SO MANY
PEOPLE ARE DYING IN FLORIDA?
>> THE NEW HEADLINE IS TRUMP
ASKS PEOPLE TO GO OUTSIDE, IT’S
DANGEROUS.
HERE WE GO, SAME OLD GROUP.
>> PEOPLE TURNING TO THESE
BRIEFINGS, THEY WANT TO GET
INFORMATION AND GUIDANCE AND
WANT TO KNOW WHAT TO DO.
THEY’RE NOT LOOKING FOR RUMORS.
>> ON THE PRESIDENT, AND YOUR
FAKE NEWS.
I’M JUST HERE TO PRESENT
TALENTS.
I’M HERE TO PRESENT IDEAS
BECAUSE WE WANT IDEAS TO GET RID
OF THIS THING AND IF HE IS
GOOD -- HEAT IS GOOD AND
SUNLIGHT IS GOOD, THAT’S A GREAT
THING AS FAR AS I’M CONCERNED.
>> Laura: IF YOU LISTEN LONG
ENOUGH TO DEMOCRAT GOVERNORS AND
THEIR POODLES IN THE PRESS THESE
DAYS, YOU’RE GOING TO REALIZE
THAT THERE REALLY IS NO GOOD
NEWS IN THIS COVID ERA.
NO DEVELOPMENT POSITIVE
ENOUGH -- POSITIVE ENOUGH TO GET
THEM TO THINK THAT THE SCIENCE
OR THE DATA IS CHANGING TO
JUSTIFY REOPENING THE STATES
THAT REALLY WANT TO OPEN ANYTIME
SOON.
NOW THINK ABOUT IT, ON
EASTER SUNDAY, WE KNEW
NEW YORK’S HOSPITAL SYSTEM,
ALTHOUGH STRETCHED IN A FEW
PLACES, WOULD NOT BE OVERWHELMED
OVERWHELMED.
WE ALSO KNEW THAT
GOVERNOR CUOMO’S CLAIM OR
INSISTENCE THAT THEY WOULD NEED
40,000 VENTILATORS WAS OFF BY AT
LEAST A FACTOR OF 6.
GUARDING AGAINST THE COLLAPSE OF
OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM WAS THE
ENTIRE JUSTIFICATION FOR THIS
NATIONAL SHUTDOWN.
>> IF WE DON’T FLATTEN THE
CURVE, HOW CONCERNED ARE YOU?
>> WELL, IF YOU HAVE A REALLY
MASSIVE INCREASE IN CASES,
THERE’S NO COUNTRY OR ANYBODY IN
THE WORLD THAT’S GOING TO BE
PERFECTLY PREPARED.
IF THAT’S THE REASON WHY WE WANT
TO BLUNT THAT CURVE.
IF YOU LET THE CURVE GET UP
THERE, THEN THE ENTIRE SOCIETY
IS GOING TO BE HIT.
>> Laura: WELL, WE KNEW WEEKS
AGO THAT OUR HOSPITALS WOULD
NOT -- WERE NOT GOING TO BREAK
UNDER COVID, BECAUSE LOOK NOW,
MILITARY HOSPITAL SHIFTS ARE
LARGELY EMPTY.
EMERGENCY HOSPITAL TENTS BARELY
UTILIZED.
NO ONE WHO IS NEEDED IN ICU BED
HAS BEEN DENIED ONE.
NO ONE WHO’S NEEDED A VENTILATOR
WAS DENIED ONE.
THIS SHOULD BE CELEBRATED.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION SHOULD
GET SOME CREDIT FOR THESE
ACHIEVEMENTS.
WE ACHIEVED THESE VERY IMPORTANT
GOALS IN A VERY CHALLENGING
TIME.
THE CURVE WAS FLATTENED, BUT NOW
THAT’S NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
NOW THEY TELL US WE CAN’T GO
BACK TO OUR OLD LIFE UNTIL
ALMOST A NEW BUREAUCRACY IS
CREATED TO SAVE US.
>> WE HAVE TO PUT TOGETHER A
TRACING ARMY.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A MASSIVE
UNDERTAKING.
THE GOOD NEWS IS,
MAYOR MICHAEL BLOOMBERG HAS
VOLUNTEERED TO HELP US DEVELOP
AND IMPLEMENT THE TRACING
PROGRAM.
BE ONE FANTASTIC.
BLOOMBERG IS IN CHARGE?
OKAY, THE GUY WHO DOESN’T THINK
CHINA’S PRESIDENT XI IS A
DICTATOR?
I’M GOING TO BE SHOCKED -- AND I
HOPE I AM SURPRISED -- BUT I’LL
BE SHOCKED IF NEW YORK TRULY
OPENS UP, I MEAN LIKE THE OLD
NEW YORK BEFORE THE ELECTION.
YOU DON’T THINK SO?
WELL, THAT’S JUST THE WAY I SEE
THINGS GOING.
MIGHT BE WRONG, I HOPE I AM
WRONG.
ALTHOUGH 26.5 MILLION AMERICANS
ARE NOW OUT OF WORK, THE
PRESIDENT’S TOP MEDICAL ADVISORS
SOLE FOCUS -- YOU CAN’T EVEN
REALLY BLAME THEM, THAT IS THEIR
ONLY FOCUS, IT’S THIS VIRUS, AND
TODAY THE TOP GUY THROUGH SHADE
ON THE TESTING ISSUE.
THE MEDIA PICKED THIS UP AND
THEN THEY THREW IT IN TRUMP’S
FACE.
>> DR. FAUCI SAID THAT THE U.S.
IS NOT IN A SITUATION WHERE WE
CAN SAY WE ARE WHERE WE WANT TO
BE WITH REGARD TO TESTING
CAPACITY.
THEY SAID WE NEED MUCH MORE
TESTING CAPACITY AS WELL AS
TESTS.
>> TO DR. FAUCI THAT WERE JUST
NOT THERE YET.
>> I DON’T AGREE WITH THAT.
I THINK WHERE DOING A GREAT JOB
ON TESTING.
IF HE SAID THAT I DON’T AGREE
WITH HIM.
>> Laura: GOOD!
I LOVE THAT, BECAUSE IF WE WAIT
FOR DR. FAUCI’S SEAL OF APPROVAL
TO REOPEN AMERICA, WE MAY NOT
HAVE IN AMERICA TO REOPEN.
AT LEAST NOT ONE WE RECOGNIZE.
I HAVE MY OWN TESTING PROPOSAL.
DO YOU WANT TO HEAR IT?
LET’S START TESTING THE LAME
DATA AND SERIES THAT HAVE BEEN
SHIFTING EVER SINCE THIS CRISIS
BEGAN.
FIRST, VERY CONFUSING, FIRST
MASKS DIDN’T HELP.
NOW THEY ARE REQUIRED IN A LOT
OF STATES.
THEY DO HELP.
FIRST WE WERE TOLD THAT MILLIONS
AND MILLIONS OF PEOPLE COULD
DIE, THEN WE WERE TOLD THE
MODELS THAT FORECASTED MILLIONS
AND MILLIONS OF PEOPLE COULD DIE
WERE BAD.
THEN WE WERE TOLD THE VIRUS WAS
FAR MORE LETHAL THAN THE FLU.
THAT WAS TERRIFYING.
NOW WE KNOW IT’S LIKELY TO BE
CLOSER TO MAYBE A REALLY
AGGRESSIVE FLU SEASON.
NOW, COURTESY OF ANYBODY STUDIES
ON BOTH THE EAST AND WEST COAST,
WE SEE
THAT THE VIRUS WAS CIRCULATING F
LONGER THAN A WE THOUGHT.
THAT MEANS MORE PEOPLE WERE
EXPOSED TO IT AND MANY OF THOSE
HAVE INNATE IMMUNITY TO IT.
>> WHAT WE FOUND SO FAR IS THE
STATEWIDE NUMBER IS 13.9% TESTED
POSITIVE FOR HAVING ANTIBODIES.
IT MEANS THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO
WERE INFECTED AND WHO DEVELOPED
THE ANTIBODIES TO FIGHT THE
INFECTION.
IF THE INFECTION RATE IS 13.9%,
THAT WOULD BE ABOUT .5% DEATH
RATE.
>> Laura: THAT TOO IS
CERTAINLY BETTER NEWS THAN WE
THOUGHT AND WE HEARD ORIGINALLY
ABOUT THIS VIRUS.
IT CERTAINLY THOUGH DOESN’T MEAN
WE NEED TO TEST 300 PLUS MILLION
AMERICANS.
DR. BIRX REFERENCED THIS THE
OTHER DAY.
WE DON’T NEED TO TEST 300 PLUS
MILLION AMERICANS CREATED A NEW
IMMUNITY CERTIFICATE FOR WORK
AND TRAVEL.
THAT SUMMER ACTUALLY PROPOSING.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS; MOST
AMERICANS DESPERATELY WANT TO
GET PAST THE SHUTDOWN.
OTHERS WANT TO PROLONG IT, IF
YOU CAN BELIEVE IT OR NOT, FOR
POLITICAL REASONS.
OR MAYBE TO EXTRACT A FEW MORE
POLICY CONCESSIONS.
THE MORE DAMAGE WE SUSTAIN, THE
MORE LIKELY A RADICAL
RESTRUCTURING OF AMERICA WILL
FOLLOW.
IT’S A DAMOCLES SWORD HANGING
OVER OUR HEADS RIGHT NOW.
THE LONGER WE STAY SHUTDOWN, THE
LESS LIKELY IT IS WE WILL
RECOVER ANYTIME SOON AND THE
MORE AMERICAN LIVES WILL BE LOST
TO THINGS LIKE DEPRESSION,
SUICIDE, ADDICTION, AND DOMESTIC
ABUSE.
AND OF COURSE THE LESS LIKELY IT
IS THAT TRUMP WILL WIN
REELECTION.
DOES ANYONE HONESTLY THINK THAT
THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN ACTUALLY
WANTS THIS COUNTRY TO OPEN UP
ANYTIME SOON?
I MEAN, THEY OBVIOUS TO PREFER
HIM IN THE BASEMENT.
FEWER MISSTEPS, FEWER GAFFES --
WELL, MOST OF THE TIME.
>> WE ARE HERE IN THE BASEMENT
OF MY HOME, WHICH IS TURNED INTO
A TELEVISION STUDIO.
I’M NOT VERY FAMILIAR WITH.
IT WAS CLEAR TO ME BY THAT TIME
THE PRESIDENT HAD NO SENSE, NO
SENSE OF SCIENCE, NO SENSE OF
RESPONSIBILITY AND I JUST
WANT -- IT JUST REALLY WORRIED
ME --
>> Laura: IT WORRIES US TOO,
JOE.
IF WE DON’T GET THIS ECONOMY
GOING AGAIN, THAT MAN COULD
BECOME PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THAT IS FAR MORE TERRIFYING THAN
ANY CORONAVIRUS AND THOSE ARE MY